[Music]
ursula kayla green's fourth earth sea
novel to hanu is taking place roughly
around the same time as her third novel
the farthest shore
in which the arc mage ged also known as
sparrowhawk was one of the
main characters and the young king to be
aaron lebonin by his true name had
accompanied ged and then ged and aaron
had confronted this mage cobb who had
opened a gateway between life and death
one that he couldn't control and ged had
to use all of his power to pour it out
in order to
solve the crisis and avert the
catastrophe that was going on at the
same time the events in tehanu are
unfolding
and there's about a year lead time from
chapter one to chapter two and then
ged is going to arrive
on the back of a dragon
as we we saw him leaving at the end of
the farthest shore the great dragon
colesian the oldest of all the dragons
and we find that tenar
is reunited with ged and what we what we
see then is a ged
who no longer is a mage let alone the
arc mage and this presents a number of
problems as we can see later on the book
but especially for ged and secondarily
for tenor
get is is saved by rn or lebanon who
carries him over the mountains of pain
and back into life
um
coliseum takes both rn and and uh gad to
rock and then takes ged further on to
gantt and that is where we
actually pick up
uh in in the chapter after ogien's death
where tenar is still there and she sees
a great thing flying
straight to gaunt it flew straight to
the overfell straight to
her
she saw the glitter of rust black scales
and the gleam of the long eye she saw
the red tongue that was a tongue of
flame the stink of burning filled the
wind as with the hissing roar the dragon
turning to land on the shelf of rock
breathed out a sigh
of fire
the dragon looked at the woman who stood
there within reach of its sith blade
talons the woman looked at the dragon
she felt the heat of its body she'd been
told that men must not look into a
dragon's eyes but that was nothing to
her
it gazed at her
straight from her from yellow eyes under
armored cara paces wide set above the
narrow nose and flaring fuming nostrils
and her small soft face and dark eyes
gazed straight at it neither of them
spoke
the dragon turned its head aside a
little so she was not destroyed when it
did speak or perhaps it laughed a great
ha of orange flame
then it lowered its body into a crouch
and spoke but not to her
ahavadre again it said mildly enough
tenor saw for the first time then the
man astride its back in the notch
between two of the high sword thorns
that rose in a row down its spine he sat
just behind the neck and above the
shoulders where the wings had root his
hands were clenched on the rust dark
male of the dragon's neck and his head
leaned against the base of the sword
thorne as if he were asleep
said the dragon a little louder
the man did not stir
the dragon turned its long head and
looked at tenor
sobrious it said in a whisper of steel
sliding over steel that word of the
language of the making she knew
ogien had taught her all she would learn
of that tongue go up the dragon said
mount
when she saw the steps to the mount
the dra the talon foot the crooked elbow
the shoulder joint the first musculature
of the wing four steps she said too ha
but not in a laugh only trying to get
her breath which kept sticking in her
throat
she climbed she
went forward past the talons in the long
lipless mouth and the long yellow eye
and mounted the shoulder she took the
man's arm he did not move but surely he
was not dead for the dragon and brought
him here and spoken to him come on she
said and then seeing his face as she
loosened the clenched grip of his left
hand come on get come on he raised his
head a little his eyes were open but
unseeing she had to climb around him
scratching her legs on the hot mailed
hide of the dragon and unclench his
right hand from a horny knob at the base
of the sword thorn she got him to take
hold of her arms and so could carry drag
him down those four strange stairs to
earth he roused enough to try to hold on
to her but there was no strength in him
so we have a description here of
her getting get back from the dragon a
ged who is completely
drained and auntie moss the witch will
come and help her with this as will
heather and thorough
for women essentially tending
as much as heather can
to to the the returned arc mage and
auntie moss says something very
interesting because auntie moss is a
witch so she can recognize
power in others and she says
uh here we go
what was he doing on the overfelt moss
asked you know him moss he was ogen's
eye hall's prentice once the witch shook
her head that was the lad from ten
alders dearie the one that's archmage
and rock now ten are knotted
no deary this looks like him but it
isn't him this may this man's no mage
not even a sorcerer
but i know him moss it's sparrowhawk
saying the name ged's use name released
a tenderness in her so for the first
time she thought and felt that this was
he indeed in all the years since she had
first seen him with her bond she saw a
light like a star in darkness
underground long ago in his face in the
light i know him moss she smiled and
then smiled more broadly he's the first
man i ever saw
moss smiled and shifted she did not like
to contradict mistress gohan but she was
perfectly unconvinced
there's tricks disguised as
transformations changes better be
careful deary how did he get where you
found him a way out here did any of them
see him come through the village none of
you saw they stared after her she tried
to save the dragon and could not
moss says tricks now that our mage is
gone there will be all sorts of
tricksters coming around tenar says i
came from ottawa to hovnor from hobnor
to gaunt with sparrowhawk in an open
boat you saw him when he brought me here
moss he was an archmage then but he was
the same the same man are there other
scars like those and moss says no but
you didn't think i would know him moss
said there's evil things in the world
mistress a thing that takes a man form
and body but his soul's gone
eaten the gebbeth
they do say once the mage sparrowhack
came here long before you came in a
thing of darkness came him came with him
following him maybe it still does
tenar says the dragon who brought him
here called him by his true name and i
know that name so there's already a
discussion going on about
who is this guy is he really get
moss is picked something out that's
essential
he doesn't have power he's not a mage
he's not a sorcerer
so can he still be
the man that tenar
knows him to be
it takes some time and eventually get
his nurse to health there's actually
kind of a funny discussion there moss is
kind of hoping he's going to die perhaps
out of drama perhaps because that means
she doesn't have to deal with him
but
tenor nurses him to health moss plays a
role in it theroux plays a small role as
well as she gets to know who this this
person is and they nurse him in ogen's
house
then get awakes and he
recognizes that he's in his teacher's
house and he asks about ogian and he
finds out that ogin had died
shortly before he actually got there
now the the key question is well
what will ged do what is he what can he
make of himself moss at one point says
something very insightful
she says
he's sort of like a boy of 15 years old
when he entered rock
and
you know he's been committed to
this
study of the high arts and doing all of
these great deeds but he's he's
essentially
like a boy he doesn't know
vast parts of the world for example he's
still a virgin because the sorcerers and
and wizards
give up that part of their life in order
to have
their magic and in this case
all
of ged's power is now gone
maw says you can tell that he doesn't
have anything
left to that
tenor and ged have a conversation
where
they're asking about what should be done
with ogian's books the runes and the two
lore books
and
he says would you be taking them with
you and she says with me he says well
you were his last student
and she said i learned to write the
runes of heartache but i've forgotten
most of that no doubt he taught me some
of the language the dragon speaks some
of that i remember but nothing else i
didn't become an adept a wizard i got
married you know would ojen have left
his books of wisdom to a farmer's wife
after a pause he said with that
expression did he not leave them to
somebody then
to you shirley
sparrowhawk said nothing you were his
last apprentice and his pride and friend
he never said it but of course they go
to you
what am i to do with them gad says
you the archmage ask me why do you make
a worse fool of me than i am god he got
up then his voice shook but don't you
can't you see all that is over
is gone
this is where we have a
wonderful explanation first however
tenor
uh
is going to to you know uh say something
how could he not actually
know
all of these these things
ged says i have no power i gave it i
spent it all i had to close so that so
that's it's done done with
she tried to deny what he said but could
not
and here we get an explanation
like pouring out a little water
a cup of water onto the sand in the dry
land i had to do that but now i have
nothing to drink
and what difference what difference did
it make does it make one cup of water in
the desert is the desert gone ah listen
it used to whisper that to me from
behind the door there listen listen and
i went into the dry land when i was
young and i met it there i became it i
married my death it gave me life water
the water of life i was a fountain a
spring flowing giving
but the springs don't run there all i
had in the end
was one cup of water and i had to pour
it out on the sand in the bed of the dry
river on the rocks in the dark so it's
gone
it's over
done
she tells him
you don't give yourself time get coming
back from death must be a long journey
even on the dragon's back
it will take time
time and quiet silence stillness you've
been hurt you will be healed
and what we find out so there's two
options here right perhaps
he can regain his powers or perhaps he's
right and it's all gone
which is it going to be
we don't know at this point
a little later on we find out
that tenor
says she doesn't believe him that it's
all gone
she wanted to rebel to deny to say to
him how can it be how can you say that
as if you'd forgotten all you know all
you learned from emoji and ant rock and
in your traveling you can't have
forgotten the words the names the acts
of your art you learned you earned your
power she kept herself from saying that
but she murmured i don't understand how
can it all
a cup of water he said tipping his glass
a little as if to pour it out
and then he says another thing and this
reveals the depth of his confusion
what i don't understand is why he
brought me back the kindness of the
young is cruelty so i'm here i have to
get on with it till i can go back he's
referring to labon and the young king
having taken him out of the realm of
death into that of life and he also
could be talking about not understanding
why the dragon brought him there
ged is bewildered he doesn't know
how to make his way
in life
no longer being a man of power having
poured out
all of his power to save the
world this provokes a sort of crisis
when we find out that a ship has come
from havnor
with the king and the king's men who are
seeking the
mage
ged wants to hide he cannot
face them he feels
and
we see in this this very same
chapter
she says
they couldn't harm you shirley ged why
would they want to
he says no no do they know you're here i
don't know
what is it you're afraid of she asked
not impatiently but with some rational
authority he put his hands across his
face rubbing his temples and forehead
rub looking down
i was he said i'm not
it was all he could say
she stopped him saying
it all right it's all
right and
here we're going to see some discussion
of
passions that we'll come back to
in a moment ged feels he he cannot face
them why because
he doesn't even know who he is anymore
he's not the archmage
he is the person who
accompanied lebanon but he's not the
same
person anymore
and he decides that he needs to leave he
actually hides out in auntie moss's
place where nobody would think to look
for him a witch hut and then he decides
i need to go somewhere else
and they have a discussion
he says
here we go um
i'll call myself something and go across
the mountain to arm with and the east
forest country where i came from they'll
be making hey there's always work at
haying and harvest she did not know how
to answer fragile and ill-looking he
would be given such work only out of
charity or brutality and if he got it he
wouldn't be able to do it
he says then she says down in the south
part of the island there's a lot of
herding sheep goats cattle they drive
them up into the hills before the long
dance and pasture them there in until
the rains they're always needing
herders
and then she says but why can't you just
stay here
and god says well not in ogian's house
that's the first place they'll come
well what if they do come what will they
want of you and ged says to be what i
was
the desolation of his voice chilled her
she was silent
trying to remember what it was like to
have been powerful to be have been the
eaten one the one priestess of the tombs
of ottawa and then lose that throw it
away to become only tenar
only herself she thought about how it
was to have been a woman in the prime of
life with children and a man and then to
lose all that becoming old and a widow
powerless but even so
she did not feel she understood his
shame his agony of humiliation perhaps
only a man could feel so a man a woman
got used to shame or perhaps auntie moss
was right and when the meat was out the
shell was empty there's a discussion
that she has with
lebanon on the ship later on
when he's saying well can you
can you find a ged for me and and he
says she says you came to find him the
archmage sparrowhack ged he said looking
at her with a faint smile you and he and
i go by our true names you and i yes but
he only to you and to me
he nodded he's in danger from envious
men men of ill will and he has
no defense now you know that
lebanon says he told me that his power
as a mage was gone spent in the act that
saved me and all of us but it was hard
to believe i wanted not to believe him
i too tennar says but it is so and so he
he wants to be alone
until his hurts are healed
lebanon says
we died together in the dry land
together we cross the mountains there
you can come back across the mountain
there is a way he knew it but the name
of the mountains is pain the stones cut
and the cuts are long to heal
and he says why does he hide from me the
young man cried and griefed and quietly
i hoped indeed to see him but if he
doesn't wish it that's the end of it
of course
and then she says surely he'll come to
you only give him time he was so badly
hurt everything was taken from you from
him but when he spoke of you when he
said your name then i saw him for a
moment as he was as he will be again
all pride pride lebanon repeated as if
startled
yes of course pride who should be proud
if not he
i always thought of him as
he was so patient lebanon said and then
laughed at the inadequacy of his
description
and here's what tenor says about him
now he has no patience
and is hard on himself beyond all reason
there is nothing we can do for him i
think except let him go his own way and
find himself at the end of his tether as
they say
at god
and
what we see here is that there's great
insight into the character of get pride
yes
and patience and he doesn't have either
of those because he lacks the power
that he
came to to view as a part of himself now
he has to determine who he is what does
he
feel what drives him i i mentioned that
a passion is particularly important so
tenor
when she's asking him what are you
afraid of and says it it's all right
she dared not touch him
lest she worsen his humiliation
by any semblance of pity
she does feel pity compassion for him
but she can't show it because that will
create greater
humiliation the opposite of pride right
she also feels anger and it says here
she was angry at him
and for him it's none of their business
she said where you are or who you are
what you choose to do or not to do if
they come crying they can leave curious
and what does ged himself feel
fear we see this talked about over and
over again
confusion
he's lost his sense of who he truly is
humiliation
ged is going to have to work out for
himself
what the rest of his life
looks like
having spent his entire life except when
he was a young child
as a mage
as a person of power as somebody
who could do things now he finds himself
without capacity and so the question is
how will he learn
what he is and who he is
you